once upon a time in a town not too
unlike your own there lived a beautiful
girl with an impossible dream
ever since she was a child she'd wish on
her birthday that one day she'd become a
real-life princess tomorrow night at her
party
she'll celebrate with all her princess
friends oh my god you have to save me Oh
alas real-life women are never
practically perfect in every way
no one will buy me a drink I hate my
stepsisters
I can't find a boyfriend and mice need
this dress what are you gonna do about
it I guess I could stand up for myself
yes yes no Jenny don't wait for a man to
save me is why it's a terrible idea to
become a Disney princess in real life
yes that's cute tops and dreamy would
day boo husband you haven't even met the
guy yet is it just me or is it really
cold in here
um Leila said can you turn the
temperature no I don't want to be a part
of this well tell him I don't know how
the thermostat is in your room duh oh
wow
[ __ ] at all tournaments are for everyone
oh it's a magic you want to make sure
he's not pretending to like you so he
doesn't have you in the back and T go to
work love is attenders
right
you'll enjoy good morning Alan morning
hey girl hey girl hey boy so I'm really
singing it again though listen because
they actually read books I'm so peculiar
you read that book like you want so much
more than this digital life I need a
challenge like that guy no she looks
dangerous I can fix him vomit River just
around the Riverbend don't do you know
how many toxins there are and that
over-processed white people crap but
then why are you gonna have for life
look around you this is where the path
of a paleo eatin free diet has porno
selected disorders and pizza
listen do you hear that
my friends recommend you switch to a
high intensity functional workout for
your muffin top they'll make you feel
like you're one with the universe you
know where is that wind coming from what
about this one so cute
happy birthday hey my boyfriend taught
me how did you guys know but it's still
oh my god Bobby mom oh you look like an
old friend and car is so oh my god you
sneaky son of a you know who I am don't
care so sorry you're about to find out
hello daddy daddy
[Music]
they never get your nose right thank you
that's straight mother it's just me and
the girls I love you forever - all right
bye
thank you for coming my mom would kill
me if she knew it was just me ad it's
good right or no and we're here for
Leila's birthday remember I'm sorry
sometimes I just get a little
overwhelmed not being locked up in my
room at all little you should spaghetti
gesundheit Italian blondie that sounds
gross you have you know thank you thank
you thank you
wait where in the world is Ariel now
that her birthday party has finally
arrived
it's time Wilma / wish remain the same
I'm not under the sea but standing
the moral of my story is changing you've
always been my friend my closest there's
a lot of hopefully repays need those
words I'm damsel in distress
[Music]
take it away over
you'll never get me
[Music]
what's the word and it's gonna be after
[Music]
[Music]
everything behind Farag I just met three
cuz he's the best bet princess can
[Music]
let some face time on the weekend I'll
tell you when I'm and I love you
variously you know what bye Felicia
I'd rather be a queen in my own right so
just count down princesses had she lived
happily ever after
oh my god I'm so late happy birthday oh
and I have to leave it midnight which is
in like five minutes so pumpkins
[Music]
you